Before you start discussing mental disorders in detail, I want to ask you
something. Do you know somebody with a mental disorder? Have you seen someone
on TV or even in public, with, let's say, schizophrenia? How did that make you
feel? Were you uncomfortable? Were you afraid? Unfortunately, historically,
people with mental disorders were shunned and even isolated from their
communities. They were also subjected to bizarre treatments. All because people
didn't understand where these mental illnesses came from, or what was causing
this behavior. Now, throughout this lesson I want you to think about this
negative stigma and how, the increase of mental health literacy, we can
diminish this stigma. Fortunately, today we've come a long way in understanding
the causes of mental illness. In fact, the're entire media campaign is
dedicated to teaching people about what mental illness is. And there's no
reason for someone today to be stigmatized because of mental illness. In fact,
we should look at it just like we do any other human illness such as diabetes.
People with diabetes face daily challenges as do people with mental illness.
However, by managing their symptoms, both can live a happy and fufilling life.